at the top so I'd ask you to bear with
me and then I'll be happy to get to your
questions first on behalf of secretary
Austin and the Department of Defense I
would like to offer our heartfelt
condolences to the families friends and
colleagues of the nine U.S army soldiers
assigned to the 101st Airborne Division
who sadly lost their lives last night
when two Black Hawk helicopters crashed
outside of Fort Campbell Kentucky
according to Army officials the
helicopters were performing planned
night training flight operations at the
time of the incident an aircraft safety
team from Fort Rucker Alabama will
arrive later today and will begin an
investigation and again our thoughts and
prayers are with the families units and
all those affected by this tragedy and
for additional question I'd refer you to
army public affairs
separately earlier today secretary
Austin met with his Romanian counterpart
minister tilvar to affirm our enduring
bilateral defense relationship
secretary Austin thanked Romania for
hosting thousands of U.S and Allied
Forces to defend NATO's Eastern flank
and for Romania's leadership role in the
Black Sea region the two leaders also
saluted the 30-year anniversary of
Romania State partnership program with
the Alabama National Guard
the secretary looks forward to Future
meetings and opportunities to work with
our Romanian allies a full readout will
be posted to defense.gov later today
on the training front since Russia's
unprovoked invasion of Ukraine in 2022
U.S European command U.S army Europe and
Africa and security assistance group
Ukraine have trained more than seven
thousand members of the Ukrainian Armed
Forces just this week 65 Ukrainian air
Defenders completed Patriot training at
Fort Sill Oklahoma and how and have now
arrived back in Europe they're
integrating with other Ukrainian air
Defenders along with donated Patriot air
defense equipment from the United States
Germany and the Netherlands once in
Ukraine the Patriot air defense system
will add to Ukraine's layered air
defenses to provide protection and
shield from Russia's wanton brutal
attacks on innocent civilians and
civilian infrastructure
meanwhile in Germany at the close of
this month more than 4 000 Ukrainian
soldiers and two brigades one equipped
with M2 Bradleys and one equipped with
Strikers will have completed combined
arms training and have returned to
Ukraine additional combined arms
training is currently underway at
grafenwer and hohenfell's training areas
in Germany with two motorized infantry
battalions consisting of 1200 Ukrainian
Armed Forces personnel operator and
maintenance training on donated
platforms is also ongoing with more than
3 000 Ukrainian soldiers having
completed platform training and 40
different programs of instruction on
more than 20 systems since April of 2022
training for Ukrainian forces is an
international effort being conducted in
partnership with our Coalition Partners
who are currently training more than 11
000 Ukrainian soldiers across 26
different nations
the U.S will continue to provide
training and work closely with our
allies and partners to ensure the
Ukrainian people have the security
assistance they need to defend the
country their country and repel Russian
aggression we remain committed to
supporting Ukraine for as long as it
takes
finally I'd also like to provide a quick
update on where things stand in regards
to our recent airstrikes against
iranian-backed groups in Syria as well
as the status of our forces who are
wounded during attacks by those groups
first we now assess that eight militants
were killed in our strikes against two
irgc could force facilities near darzer
by U.S Air Force f-15e Fighters assigned
a U.S Air Force's Central again these
Precision strikes were taken to protect
and defend U.S Personnel second the six
U.S Personnel wounded in the March 23rd
attack against a coalition based near
hasaka in northeastern Syria are all in
stable condition two of the Wounded U.S
service members have already returned to
duty one service member was medically
evacuated to launch Tool to receive
treatment and two U.S service members
and the U.S contractor are receiving
medical treatment in Iraq separately the
U.S service member injured in the attack
against Mission support site Conoco on
March 24 is also in stable condition and
continues to receive Medical Care
as secretary Austin made clear during
his contest Congressional testimony this
week we will take all necessary measures
to defend our troops and our interests
overseas to underscore in response to a
pattern of Iranian and iran-backed
attacks against U.S personnel and
facilities in Iraq and Syria and the
continuing threat of future such attacks
the United States has taken and as
necessary will continue to take military
action against the irgc and its
Affiliates this includes the use of
force against irgc and irgc affiliate
personnel and facilities and the U.S
Central Command area of responsibility
with the intention to convince the
Iranians to de-escalate threats against
the United States our interests and our
people again we do not see conflict with
Iran but we will always protect our
people and with that I'm happy to take
your questions go to Associated Press
leader beldor
thanks Pat
um one uh quick thing and then a
question
on Syria you mentioned uh U.S forces
that are injured and also insurgents
that were injured are there and killed
is that eight militants is that the
total number of militants that USS
killed and or injured by U.S strikes all
together during that time period that's
correct and then are there any
additional U.S injuries or other
anything else that's happened any other
strikes that have happened and then I
have a question sure so no no additional
strikes than the the ones that we've
announced
um and that that is correct we assess
that eight militants were killed as a
result of those airstrikes in addition
to the the seven injured service members
that I highlighted there were an
additional six U.S service members that
have subsequently been diagnosed with
traumatic brain injury as a result of
the Iranian back attacks specifically
for U.S service members at the Coalition
base near hasaka during the March 23rd
attack and two admission support site
Green Village on the March 24 attack on
a standard procedure all all Personnel
in the vicinity of a blast are screened
for traumatic brain injuries so these
additional injuries were identified
during post-attack medical screenings
and are all the screenings complete
those will be ongoing is a matter of
standard procedure so there is always
the possibility that there could be
additional but that that's where we're
at right now okay then just one quick
thing the White House announced uh
earlier today that Russia has reached
out again to North Korea for sir some
additional weapons Etc support for the
war has the Pentagon seen any indication
that any other additional weapons or any
other Military Support is either
preparing or moving from North Korea to
Russia we have not at this time
um beyond the uh which had been
previously announced beyond the the
shipment that Wagner group had
previously arranged for but it's again
something we continue to keep a close
eye on
all right let's go ahead and go to Genie
and then we'll go to Idris
thank you General I have two occasions
the U.S Senate Foreign Relations
Committee has an has mentioned the
review of the lead deployment of
tactical nuclear weapons in South Korea
what is the pentagon's position on that
I'm sorry Janet I didn't understand you
yes the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee has mentioned the review of
redeployment of tactical nuclear weapons
um well of course we'll always continue
to work closely with the Congress our
current policy is the denuclearization
Contin the denuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula so at this time that
will continue to remain I want to need a
more stronger extended deterrence in
South Korea well you know as you know we
are in constant discussion with our
South Korean allies and our partners in
the region on extended deterrence to
ensure that we can deter aggression from
countries like North Korea or China and
will continue to stay focused on that
thank you
now let me let me go ahead and start the
stations in South Korea recently started
the resuming training how do you view it
and do you have a another plans to
additional the deployment to Korea yeah
I don't have anything to announce right
now let me go to Idris
just on the TBI that you announced uh
the troops still on the basis or have
they been medevaced out and on the
helicopter crash um in Kentucky uh do
you have a sense of the ages the range
of Ages of those who were killed and are
you confident in the aircraft are you
looking at a potential Stand Down the
army that is sure
um so in terms of the uh the the troops
that were diagnosed with TBI to my
knowledge they are being treated at
those bases right now although there is
the potential uh obviously for
additional medical care so I'd refer you
to centcom for the status of that in
terms of the the Blackhawk crash so
right now the Army is going through the
process of next of kin notification so
it would be inappropriate at this point
to release any additional information
certainly more will be provided as it
becomes available in terms of any type
of stand down for aircraft none that I'm
tracking at this point of course that's
certainly uh you know the program of the
army and as it manages its aircraft but
again I'd refer you to them for the the
current status
thank you let me go to body and then row
thank you General I have one follow-up
on on Syria and a separate question so
the eight militants that you uh have
confirmation they directed those strikes
are you able to confirm what group they
belong to and whether they are Iranians
or not
um so fatty what I would tell you is uh
to my knowledge not Iranians but these
were uh individuals that are associated
with the irgc
okay and then on
um in a congress Congressman Jamal
Bowman is leading an effort calling on
the administration to determine
determine whether any U.S weapons have
been used in uh by the by Israel to in
violation of U.S laws or human rights
violations so first does the Secretary
have any concerns that U.S weapons have
been may have been used in occupy
occupied West Bank in violation of human
rights in light of the recent escalation
we saw and does he support measures uh
to to make sure that no U.S weapons are
used to violate the rights of the or
kill for that matter
civilians within the Palestinian
population thank you yeah thanks fardi
so a couple things there so first of all
you know as it pertains to Congressional
correspondence we of course will respond
to Congress appropriately and so I don't
want to get ahead of an any kind of
response when it comes to security
assistance to Israel you know our our
commitment to Israel's security is
Ironclad we will continue to be
committed to their qualitative military
Edge uh in the region
um but you've also heard us say you know
most recently when secretary Austin
visited Israel speaking with Israeli
leaders and highlighting that our Focus
continues to remain on uh communicating
with Israel with the Palestinians and
our partners in the region to try to
de-escalate tensions restore calm and we
would call for no action that is going
to increase the insecurity in the region
thank you let me go ahead and go to Rio
and then I'll come back over here
thank you very much the Taiwanese
president Thai is now in New York and
China said China might retaliate so have
you have you seen any irregular movement
of the Chinese military or any
indications of of Chinese preparing
major exercises around Taiwan over the
last few days yeah thanks Rose so um
without really getting into intelligence
I would say we have not seen anything uh
particular concerning or out of the
ordinary at this stage we continue to
monitor of course
go to Kelly
thank you so much General it's Brandi
from defense
considering the number of catastrophic
military training incidents in the last
decade does secretary Austin see the
need to launch a broader oversight
review that should be conducted across
all the services on Aviation and other
training mishaps that have put lives in
danger yeah thanks for the question and
I apologize about getting your name
wrong there um
so a couple things so first of all
in the United States military we take
safety very very seriously each of the
services
each of our organ each down you know
each Aviation unit down to the unit
level will have a safety Branch whose
primary role is to
do exactly that maintain constant
situational Awareness on safety and so
that is that is something that is baked
into our culture and something that we
will continue to do I'm not aware of a
DOD wide review certainly anytime
there's an accident
um you know it is incredibly unfortunate
something we take incredibly seriously
and and every single investigation is
intent intended to help us learn from
that to prevent future accidents from
happening unfortunately a lot of what we
do is inherently dangerous and so
um you know this is something that we're
always going to constantly be working at
and as in the case of the Blackhawk
helicopter crashes you heard me say
there's a team already enroute to
Alabama to begin that investigation so
again it's something that we as a
department will always take very very
seriously and and we'll just never let
up on that before my other question the
team on the way associated with OSD or
is that strictly an army team that my
understand it's an army investigation
and that's standard for these types of
crashes so if you know in the Air Force
for example if it was an Air Force
accident there'd be a team in the Air
Force that's assigned to investigate
that sure I'm just thinking
I've been a lot of people seem to be
dying and training more than combat
lately so other question
um has secretary Austin been briefed on
the auto abort of the SpaceX SDA tranche
zero launch this morning what are his
comments and do you all remain confident
in your plans moving forward yeah so the
the secretaries I'm sure you can imagine
is is aware of a lot of things certainly
uh it has been been briefed on that I
just to provide some perspective uh not
uncommon for space launches uh to go
through a checklist before launch to
make sure that there's no anomalies
given the expense of the payloads and
Safety and Security so my understanding
is that there will be another attempt
tomorrow for this launch and so we'll
certainly be keeping an eye on that
thank you go to Liz yep
thank you
to follow up on Brandy's question so I
understand there's no DOD investigation
going on with the Blackhawk crash
um the investor the investigation that
will start as soon as the team arrives
does that have the potential depending
on the findings to ground other
Blackhawk helicopter helicopters
um basically what depending on what they
find how how big of a problem could this
be what does it have the potential to
mean
um so so great question
um again you know any any commander
anywhere has the depending on the
situation has the ability to to stand
down equipment or call for those kinds
of things I don't want to get into
hypotheticals or get ahead of ourselves
we need to allow time for this
investigation uh but for example anytime
there's the potential for a fleet of
aircraft uh to have some type of
systemic issue then certainly again
those fleets can be stood down you've
seen us do that with other types of
aircraft in the past again I'm not aware
of anything like that right now for the
Blackhawk we need to allow time for the
investigation to run its course again
without getting into hypotheticals
during the course of that investigation
were something to become were we to
become aware of a need to do that or if
there was something that was systemic
then certainly that is a step that could
be taken but again we need to allow time
for this investigation to to run its
course thank you
Warren
just a very quick question on the
ukrainians being trained the numbers you
gave there the ukrainians who are
currently in training is there an effort
to get that training completed before it
anticipated Ukrainian counter-offensive
um is that sort of the schedule you're
working on and are there subsequent
plans to bring more troops in following
this group on the combined arms training
and other systems what are you trying to
ask me for the date of a Ukrainian
counter offensive I'm just kidding yeah
so so a couple things there uh so first
of all again I'm not going to talk about
potential future operations I'm not
going to talk about timelines
um you know this training this this
program for the combined arms training
began in January uh and at the time we
announced that that the course for the
Battalion level courses would take about
five weeks each as we cycled forces
through so so that is on schedule as
these tranches of forces come through uh
to provide that mechanized Brigade
combined arms training that is all on
track and on Pace in terms of additional
Ukrainian forces as has been the case
from the beginning that is that is a
iterative discussion with the ukrainians
in terms of what their needs are and
then how you know keeping in mind that
they need to be able to ensure that they
have the forces they need on the actual
Battlefield so
um you know we'll continue to to train
them uh continue to have those
discussions on what kind of future
training might they need but in terms as
it relates to any type of potential
future operations I'm just not going to
be able to talk about that thank you
Carla
um last week the secretary said that the
no one no group could strike the U.S and
U.S forces with impunity so can you help
us understand why there hasn't been
another retaliatory strike in Syria as a
result of the three attacks that
happened over the weekend one that
injured a U.S service member and and now
we're hearing and caused at least two
tbis thank you so so again you know we
we took action uh we we struck two irgc
kids Force targets as I highlighted and
that was proportionate action and it was
deliberate action in order to again send
a message that to your point that U.S
forces will not be attacked with
impunity and so as I highlighted in my
topper we will continue to take
appropriate action at a time and place
of our choosing to ensure that our
forces are protected as it pertains to
uh you know potential or speculative
future operations again I'm not ever
going to talk about potential future
operations or speculate on those things
other than to say that we mean it when
we say it we will take appropriate
action to protect our forces and we will
always do so at a time and place of our
choosing thank you
you go to the back of the room there
thank you just to follow up about a
visit of the president of Taiwan on
Chinese threats did did the United
States military have to take any
precautions additional precautions
because of this visit uh so so really I
mean just again to put this in a
perspective uh president-sized Transit
of the United States
um you know the the Department of
Defense of course we're monitoring that
for obvious reasons but really not not
playing much of a role in that regard so
again we'll continue to keep an eye on
the indo-pacific region uh and I'll just
leave it at that thank you very much
Tony
a couple questions questions on
classification issues uh this week a new
uh Washington DC organization called the
new non-proliferation policy education
center issued a risk scathing report and
over classification uh the Wall Street
Journal and stars and stripes picked it
up so troops are reading about it it was
pretty critical and it says here that
overclassification an overclassification
epidemic is killing off our nation's
common defense not protecting it can you
broadly address that claim
yeah so Tony I don't I don't necessarily
want to comment on somebody else's
report when it comes to classification
and we've talked about this uh in the
past you know certainly as DOD members
were all required to take training
regular training on the appropriate
classification of information and and
that's something that that we continue
to work at and something we know we can
continue to do better as we've talked
about in the past there is an ongoing
review and certainly when that review is
complete we we may have more to talk
about on that
um but but again it is something that we
are aware of that we need to address and
work on May I follow up the review was
by secretary Hicks was supposed to be
done by like January 30th according to
the Appropriations Committee legislation
last year she has the Pentagon hasn't
sent it over yet why the delay and when
might be completed yeah let me take that
question I'll come back to you okay
thanks thank you you feel better thanks
is it that obvious
yes ma'am
they give my question my question is
related to Ukrainian Aid so last week
Republican lawmakers sent the letter to
President Biden
urging the administration to provide
Ukraine with the cluster Munitions so
does DOD support using cluster Munitions
in Ukraine you yeah so again I'm not
going to get ahead of any announcements
that we're making
um so I don't have any anything further
on that thank you
go here and we'll go there
Christina Anderson thank you General
um
as Russia assumes the chairmanship of
the
U.N security Council are we is there are
you tracking any potential for them to
use this as an opportunity on the
battlefield in Ukraine or elsewhere
around the world in some contested areas
I am not that's probably a question
better addressed by the the U.S
delegation to the U.N again you know we
we've seen in the past Russia attempts
attempt to use some of its uh
International positions to obviously
advocate for its position on things but
from a DOD standpoint I don't I don't
have anything to provide on that and a
follow-up if I may
um regarding the helicopter crash in
Kentucky
um it seems that training incidents are
part of the risk of that service members
must bear uh is part of the service to
the nation
as we go forward in a world that's
fairly
contested as it seems it's more
contested feels more contested every day
can we anticipate perhaps additional
risk that the service members must
assume in training or is this something
that
we hope to mitigate thank you yeah
so so when it comes to military training
we're always going to try to to take
into account mitigating some of the
risks associated with that training as I
mentioned before a lot of the training
that our service members do is by nature
dangerous right whether it's live fire
exercises whether it's aircraft training
whether it's you know training on on
ships at Sea that there are many
dangerous aspects of that and so writing
into training plans
efforts to ensure that that safety is
taken into account as I mentioned our
safety offices work very diligently
every day trying to identify potential
hazards in order to mitigate and reduce
risks that said that risk will always be
there and so again this will be one of
those things that we're just going to
always have to work at and just never be
satisfied with and so we're obviously
committed to doing that because at the
end of the day it's about ensuring that
we have U.S service members who are
ready to go wherever we need them to go
when we need them to go there to do the
important work that we're asking them to
do on behalf of our nation thank you
time for just a couple more
yeah last question yes ma'am
thank you yesterday secretary Austin
agreed that there hadn't been any
accountability for the U.S withdrawal
from
Afghanistan I'm just wondering if you
can clarify that statement did he mean
it's because is it needed or is there
more actions that need to be taken in
DOD or somewhere else in the uh the
White House the executive branch to to
review
person's actions or I'm just can you
expand a little bit more on what what he
meant with that scene when you say
agreed there was no accountability would
you didn't I don't recall him saying
that he was he
yeah he said I agree there's no
accountability
he said I agree
okay
um I think the the context here uh you
know in terms of
secretary Austin's view of the situation
in Afghanistan uh and and how the
withdrawal went so first of all the
secretary was
um
you know his views on the performance of
our service members our men and women
during a very chaotic time
um and he felt they performed
magnificently under incredibly trying
conditions
um you know obviously uh very regretful
in terms of the fact that we lost 13
service members in a suicide attack
during that that event
but we had a mission to do it was to
withdraw our forces from Afghanistan and
again despite incredibly uh chaotic
situations we were able to evacuate more
than 124 000 people from that country
and we did it in a way that the United
States military only could working very
closely with our partners and allies
again in a very very challenging
situation so again I think that's the
important context to understand here is
that the secretary is incredibly proud
of the way that our men and women
performed in a situation that was
obviously a a very uh trying and chaotic
situation so thank you thank you very
much everybody appreciate it